sold the show to abc and i think i'm at
the point my career now where
you know we get a certain level of
frustration where
i keep doing these auditions and
people are telling me no for [ __ ] that i
really don't want to do like you're
telling me
people are telling you what i'm saying
it's a certain point where you make that
transition where yeah
you know you
of course it's something that's a good
opportunity to audition but
we don't you get a certain point you
don't have the same energy for an
audition
because you know that you could create
something doper
and your situation is a lot different
than mine because
you've created something that can nobody
take away from
you know yeah i i have to say that um
when i was young and younger in the
business i was like
why i don't think it's gonna happen for
me you know i see all these guys
get big things and you know there were a
couple of years where nothing really
happened
but when i realized that my age now is
is
you know i've always had a slow rise you
know my [ __ ] has been just
very slow i say that all the time i said
you got a tortoise in the hair right
yeah yeah then what happened is the
thing especially like you know people
you started with
people try to compare what your career
is to somebody else's yeah people always
tell me all the time donnie you're so
funny everything i've seen you and
you've been funny
you've been funny as a [ __ ] dramatic
actor on the wire you've been funniest
dramatic actor on the corner
the little small little netflix things
you've done you [ __ ] killed that [ __ ]
why i was like you you never know yeah
and
the bottom line is as long as you can
maintain your happiness on the ride
you'll be good yeah some people can't
brodie
yeah our friend yeah you know
dope guy i did a movie with brody like
26 years ago he was the same management
in new york right
and it was so tragic when i heard the
news of that because i was like
this dude never
stopped trying you're gonna make me cry
again
it never stopped trying yeah until he
finally stopped trying
you're gonna make me cry again and the
thing is
[ __ ] you man people say i'm the life
but you know what i'm saying that's the
side that's the side of our business
that's the side of our business yeah
yeah that's the side
this is what i told you out there right
i go
okay this is how i this is how i know i
gotta do a shout out to you real quick
shout out to uh eb
nah evie chappelle that's uh dave
chappelle's youngest son
and i was upset when i heard because i
was talking about my podcast
and then the person i was talking to
said that uh
evie's favorite podcast is
your [ __ ] podcast and i was so
[ __ ] pissed i'm like i love you evie
i love you i was like
do the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but his brother sully likes my pockets
but eb
i love you and since you like this
[ __ ] podcast so much let him
make your favorite [ __ ] fish
[ __ ] no no he loves my fish it's
hard to understand but eb loves that
[ __ ] fish
let me say this real quick so when i was
out there and we were talking about
i go i think i have a pretty good idea
somewhat
you know and i look at donnell because
here's how i knew when
we were at this is before the pandemic
and adam egan
somebody was after you in the lineup at
the in the or and